I am the grandson of immigrants from Japan who went to America.
I was four years old when Pearl Harbor was bombed on December 7th, 1941 by Japan.
And overnight, the world was plunged into a world war.
My brother and I were in the living room looking out the front window,...
...and we saw two soldiers marching up our driveway.
They carried bayonets on their rifle.
They stomped up the front porch and banged on the door.
My father answered it, and the soldiers ordered us out of our home.
We were taken from our home...
...and loaded on to train cars with other Japanese-American families.
There were guards stationed at both ends of each car as if we were criminals.
We were taken on that train for four days and three nights to the swamps of Arkansas.
I still remember the barbed wire fence that confined me.
I remember the tall sentry tower with the machine guns pointed at us.
I remember the searchlight that followed me when I made the night runs...
...from my barrack to the latrine.
When the war ended, we were released...
...and given a one-way ticket to anywhere in the United States.